Caption: hello
Caption: I'm not used to handheld mic so I'm not
Caption: sure how far to do it
Caption: welcome to the 315 session
Caption: uh today we have Sarah migio she will be
Caption: giving her talk failure 101. what life
Caption: lessons can teach us about better
Caption: software development
Caption: Sarah has had a career that can only be
Caption: described as a collectic
Caption: but the prevailing theme has been a
Caption: passion for bringing people together and
Caption: supporting teams to use the data to
Caption: drive the best outcomes for customers
Caption: stakeholders and business give a warm
Caption: welcome to Sarah
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you
Caption: um now who here has ever failed at
Caption: something before
Caption: yep failed to meet a deadline personally
Caption: I failed to get out of bed with my first
Caption: one this morning so I made it it's fine
Caption: and who here has been part of a software
Caption: project that's failed before
Caption: yeah maybe an incident
Caption: well I'm not surprised it's pretty much
Caption: everyone in this room because failure is
Caption: a big part of life and it's a massive
Caption: part of working in Tech and in building
Caption: software
Caption: code fails to execute all the time bugs
Caption: pop up seemingly from nowhere and
Caption: sometimes even with an IDE you fail to
Caption: find that one missing semicolon
Caption: now we as individuals are usually pretty
Caption: good at finding the cause of these
Caption: little errors
Caption: but when it comes to a big project often
Caption: it's not until that post-modern retro or
Caption: that post-incident review that you sit
Caption: back and go
Caption: yeah that's why we failed
Caption: well luckily
Caption: I've been failing pretty much my whole
Caption: life I constantly fail
Caption: and I've worked in probably more
Caption: Industries than any one person should
Caption: have this is just a selection and in the
Caption: past few years I have worked in incident
Caption: and problem management so fixing
Caption: problems software development causing
Caption: them and as a scrum Master trying to
Caption: help others not cause them
Caption: and I am also on Twitter I often fail to
Caption: update this but you're welcome to follow
Caption: me anyway
Caption: now the benefit of me having worked in
Caption: so many Industries is that I've seen
Caption: what failure looks like across all kinds
Caption: of projects
Caption: and I can tell you that it's the same
Caption: few things that cause a project of
Caption: whatever kind to fail
Caption: but one thing I can't fail to do today
Caption: is to mention the amazing sponsors who
Caption: make this possible so if you haven't
Caption: already please make sure you go get your
Caption: treasure map stamped when some pretty
Caption: cool stuff
Caption: so today I'm going to use a couple of
Caption: examples from my personal life don't
Caption: worry they are embarrassing to walk you
Caption: through some of the mistakes that we
Caption: made and how they can snowball into
Caption: those big failures
Caption: so I'm going to take you back a bit in
Caption: my life to my childhood
Caption: I'm about five years old
Caption: the start of term two and I'm at a brand
Caption: new school
Caption: I'm in the pre-primary class and I'm
Caption: standing at the starting line of the
Caption: very first event of the day at our
Caption: Athletics Carnival
Caption: and then the sports teacher comes over
Caption: to us and explains what this event's all
Caption: about
Caption: they tell us that what you need to do is
Caption: to try and run and reach the Finish Line
Caption: as fast as you possibly can
Caption: now I've been around the block a bit
Caption: we're in the lead-up to the Sydney
Caption: Olympic Games I've seen a running race
Caption: on TV
Caption: I know exactly what it is that I'm doing
Caption: here right and I look down the track and
Caption: I can see the Finish Lines in each of
Caption: the lanes each with that finishing
Caption: ribbon set across between the two posts
Caption: so I think to myself yeah I've got this
Caption: and you know what I'm going to show
Caption: everyone at my new school that I am
Caption: pretty cool
Caption: so
Caption: at the Finish Line Ready Set Go
Caption: and we're off we're running I'm running
Caption: as fast as my little legs can carry me
Caption: and the finish line is very rapidly
Caption: coming up
Caption: I get there first I'm gonna win this so
Caption: I'm running and I hit the finish line
Caption: and I fall flat on my face
Caption: you see what I thought was a set of
Caption: Finish Lines turned out to be a set of
Caption: hurdles
Caption: and
Caption: at five years old I hadn't encountered
Caption: this before and not only did I fall down
Caption: I caused a terrible domino effect
Caption: children's limbs flying everywhere as
Caption: the person next to me fell down and
Caption: cascaded down the lanes
Caption: so where did I quite literally I might
Caption: add
Caption: fall down
Caption: well it started with assumptions
Caption: I assumed that because this looked
Caption: similar to something that I'd seen on TV
Caption: that it must be the same
Caption: and not only that the sports teacher
Caption: assumed that everyone at that stance
Caption: like that starting line had been there
Caption: the term before and attended the class
Caption: where we learned exactly what hurdles
Caption: were and how to jump over them and not
Caption: run through them
Caption: the second mistake here was my own fear
Caption: of embarrassment I was the new kid at
Caption: school so even though I recognized this
Caption: didn't look exactly the same to what I'd
Caption: seen on TV I was too scared to ask that
Caption: question
Caption: and thirdly there was some really poor
Caption: communication
Caption: when that Sports teacher told us to run
Caption: and try and reach the Finish Line as
Caption: fast as possible
Caption: did that really communicate what you
Caption: needed to do in an event like hurdles
Caption: and look it boils down to the fact that
Caption: we didn't clearly communicate or
Caption: understand the requirements and this
Caption: isn't something that affects just me
Caption: we see it every day the 125 million
Caption: dollar Mars probe that failed because
Caption: people assumed they were working in the
Caption: same units or the junior developer who
Caption: picks up a card for an API to do
Caption: something
Caption: and then they build it in Java only to
Caption: find out that hey it was meant to be
Caption: built in C sharp
Caption: so how do we avoid this
Caption: firstly validate your assumptions check
Caption: with your team members with your product
Caption: owner or program manager and if possible
Caption: with your stakeholders and end users
Caption: ask the stupid questions don't be like
Caption: me and let your fear of embarrassment
Caption: get in the way of you asking a question
Caption: because I can pretty much guarantee
Caption: someone else in the team has the same
Caption: thoughts as you
Caption: and make sure that you have a shared
Caption: understanding of what's required spend
Caption: that bit of extra time in your Inception
Caption: and then you document that for the next
Caption: person
Caption: moving on a little bit a little bit
Caption: older a little bit wiser
Caption: and I'm in my final year of University
Caption: I'm working on my thesis which is
Caption: investigating potential causes of liver
Caption: disease
Caption: now for anybody who's done biochemistry
Caption: and seen diagrams like this before I
Caption: apologize for reinflicting that trauma
Caption: on you
Caption: for everybody else I'm going to try and
Caption: explain what it is that I was working on
Caption: without throwing too many terms like de
Caption: novo lipogenesis or asterified fatty
Caption: acids at you
Caption: so the liver is the body's Central hub
Caption: for metabolism each one of the arrows on
Caption: this diagram represents a pathway where
Caption: something is metabolized from one thing
Caption: to another
Caption: for your context there's about 135 of
Caption: them I cannot fit them all on one
Caption: diagram
Caption: um but my team was invested in
Caption: particularly two Pathways we're looking
Caption: at how the body breaks down fats and I
Caption: was specifically focusing on how the
Caption: body metabolizes iron and as a whole
Caption: we're looking to see what happens
Caption: between these two Pathways when the
Caption: liver gets stressed
Caption: so for your understanding we selected
Caption: our Gene targets those are the items
Caption: that are sort of like boxed in blue very
Caption: carefully
Caption: we then determined what our experimental
Caption: controls would be we worked very hard to
Caption: ensure that we're using the same
Caption: consistent methodology
Caption: and then we got to work
Caption: for three months we tested each of these
Caption: targets and then we came together as a
Caption: whole Lab group to share sort of our
Caption: version of a proof of concept and yeah
Caption: all of the genes all of these things in
Caption: blue were giving us the results that
Caption: were expected the ones that we thought
Caption: would be active were and the ones that
Caption: we thought would be quiet weren't really
Caption: showing us any results
Caption: so we carried on with our work
Caption: over the next 12 months I tested these
Caption: targets so many times I painstakingly
Caption: followed our protocols even down to like
Caption: timing the seconds out
Caption: and I honestly crunch more data than I
Caption: think anybody knows what to do with
Caption: and then at the end of 12 months we came
Caption: together again each person who took a
Caption: different pathway in the liver and
Caption: shared our results
Caption: the only problem was they didn't line up
Caption: now as anybody who's been part of a
Caption: software project maybe you've dedicated
Caption: a lot of time of your life to that and
Caption: had it fall over or fail at the last
Caption: minute
Caption: realizing that your work
Caption: for 12 months of your life was wasted
Caption: that's a kick in the the guard that's a
Caption: slap in the face and that's exactly how
Caption: I was feeling when I found out that 12
Caption: months of my life were effectively
Caption: wasted
Caption: effectively
Caption: we failed to test everything that we
Caption: should have so what didn't metabolize
Caption: here in my piece of work
Caption: well by only testing those Gene Targets
Caption: in blue and not everything that was
Caption: happening between them we relied on the
Caption: equivalent of unit tests for our entire
Caption: measure of quality
Caption: and we didn't test the entire process
Caption: end to end what happens between every
Caption: single one of those 135 Pathways in the
Caption: liver so we didn't even have anything to
Caption: compare the results that we did generate
Caption: to
Caption: and we only tested and planned for the
Caption: happy path so what happens according to
Caption: plan you know how the Libra is meant to
Caption: metabolize things
Caption: and given that in this scenario we were
Caption: deliberately trying to stress it to
Caption: break down the metabolic processes we
Caption: really should have considered that
Caption: unhappy path
Caption: we just simply didn't test everything
Caption: that we needed to
Caption: and look that isn't something that's
Caption: just restricted to medical research
Caption: inadequate testing also contributed to
Caption: the failure of TSB bank's software
Caption: migration in 2018 and that cost them 330
Caption: million pounds and lost them 80 000
Caption: customers so that's a pretty big mistake
Caption: for not testing something
Caption: so how do you get over this how do you
Caption: overcome a lack of testing
Caption: if at all possible consult the subject
Caption: matter experts before you start your
Caption: development work they can help you
Caption: ensure that you're testing everything
Caption: that you need to and that your
Caption: development practices are robust
Caption: please don't just rely on unit tests as
Caption: foundational as important as they are if
Caption: they're your only measure of quality you
Caption: could be potentially missing something
Caption: that will cause you an error or a bug
Caption: later
Caption: and consider the happy and the unhappy
Caption: Parts in your testing because we all
Caption: know users I am a user and I know that I
Caption: mistake make mistakes all of the time
Caption: and I will find some way to break
Caption: something
Caption: now we come to the failure that frankly
Caption: I'm the most embarrassed about and the
Caption: most modified so guys strap yourselves
Caption: in if you thought that was heavy
Caption: you see I was asked to bake a cake
Caption: it was for a friend's 21st birthday
Caption: party and they're a massive fan of the
Caption: movie Madagascar
Caption: um so we thought hey it's their 21st why
Caption: not Embrace this and Go full kids party
Caption: I'm talking balloons birthday Partners
Caption: everywhere pinata hanging from the
Caption: ceiling
Caption: and then we thought hey why don't we do
Caption: the birthday cake in the shape of their
Caption: favorite character from the movie King
Caption: Julien
Caption: for those of you who haven't seen the
Caption: movie or have forgotten is this kooky
Caption: looking Lima with the crown
Caption: so why was I asked to bake the cake
Caption: well I have a confession for you guys
Caption: I'm a stress Baker so when I get
Caption: stressed I bake I baked recently in
Caption: preparing for this talk that's how
Caption: stressed I was
Caption: and it's a hobby that I've kept up for
Caption: the past several years
Caption: I have baked everything from fully
Caption: edible terrariums so I'm talking candy
Caption: glass cake for the soil plastic sorry uh
Caption: not plastic um matte modeling chocolate
Caption: I forget the fancy French name for it
Caption: but really fancy things I've even made
Caption: cartoon character cakes before like
Caption: Finding Dory or Dory from Finding Nemo
Caption: if you didn't see the sequel
Caption: so making something like this amazing
Caption: thing
Caption: shouldn't be too far out of my
Caption: wheelhouse right shouldn't be too far
Caption: from my level of expertise
Caption: so I did what anybody would do in this
Caption: situation and I went hunting on the
Caption: internet for inspiration this is just
Caption: one of the items that I sort of like
Caption: based my cake on
Caption: I worked out everything that I would
Caption: need and then I pre-ordered all of my
Caption: ingredients all the things I'd need for
Caption: decoration
Caption: fast forward a couple of weeks the day
Caption: before the party and I finished work at
Caption: lunch time so I finished early and then
Caption: I go down to collect everything that I'd
Caption: pre-ordered
Caption: only problem was they didn't have half
Caption: the stuff I ordered including the cake
Caption: that I special ordered
Caption: so with very few options you know I'm a
Caption: day away from this party
Caption: I had to come up with another solution
Caption: so I came up with a list of things that
Caption: I thought I could substitute in terms of
Caption: ingredients I grabbed everything that I
Caption: would need to bake cakes myself and I
Caption: headed home and got baking
Caption: I just pulled the cakes out of the oven
Caption: when I got a phone call from the other
Caption: person organizing the party asking me to
Caption: do them just a little favor and could I
Caption: run down and pick up the guy's birthday
Caption: present
Caption: now cakes have to cool after coming out
Caption: of the oven and I definitely can't start
Caption: carving them up or decorating them until
Caption: that's done
Caption: and I don't know if you guys know this
Caption: but birthday presents kind of a big deal
Caption: so sure
Caption: but as anybody who works in Perth CBD
Caption: knows that on a Friday afternoon pick
Caption: our traffic
Caption: is insane
Caption: so my quick errand quickly turned into a
Caption: three hour long trip
Caption: and that meant that I just didn't have
Caption: the time that I needed that evening to
Caption: start assembling this cake
Caption: no problem I wake up even earlier the
Caption: next morning I get slicing my cake down
Caption: into all the shapes that I need I start
Caption: getting ready to assemble it
Caption: only to sort of get tapped on the
Caption: shoulder and told you know that we're
Caption: hosting this party right so we need to
Caption: start setting up at about mid-afternoon
Caption: and you need to go get ready
Caption: so I'm looking at my half assembled cake
Caption: and I know that it's going to take me at
Caption: least another eight hours to finish
Caption: assembling this especially given I'm
Caption: working with things that I am not
Caption: familiar with
Caption: so
Caption: something had to give
Caption: I decided I had to start from scratch I
Caption: re-baked some cakes
Caption: and here's what I was able to deliver
Caption: in a little bit over four hours I
Caption: completely re-baked cakes and I
Caption: decorated now look it kind of it's the
Caption: minimum viable product right it's a cake
Caption: it kind of resembles King Julian on it
Caption: and look when I cut I cut it open you
Caption: know the stuff did spill out like a
Caption: pinata cake
Caption: but it wasn't even close to what I
Caption: wanted to deliver it wasn't sort of what
Caption: we promised and it definitely wasn't
Caption: like this image which is what I was
Caption: aiming for
Caption: so I was still understandably
Caption: embarrassed and yeah here I am sharing
Caption: it all with you guys
Caption: so how did I somebody who's got years of
Caption: experience with baking become a nailed
Caption: it contender
Caption: well
Caption: the resources and tools that I planned
Caption: on having ingredients I was familiar
Caption: with pre-made cakes so I could focus on
Caption: decorating had to be substituted
Caption: the organizer didn't consider
Caption: conflicting priorities I mean yeah a
Caption: birthday present's important but so's
Caption: the birthday cake and realistically I
Caption: should have pushed back on me being the
Caption: person to pick it up surely someone else
Caption: could have
Caption: and I also failed to plan for changes in
Caption: my own capacity or for these unexpected
Caption: things to happen I could have allowed
Caption: myself even more time
Caption: at the end it just came down to pool
Caption: planning now this is a contributor to 71
Caption: of projects that fail so it's a big one
Caption: and look it's not just related to bank
Caption: to baking or anything else like that
Caption: poor planning caused a three-time cost
Caption: overrun for the U.S national gas
Caption: company's Erp update so they originally
Caption: budgeted 330 million dollars and it cost
Caption: them just over a billion to finish that
Caption: project
Caption: that's a lot of money could have been
Caption: spent elsewhere
Caption: so how do we avoid becoming nailed at
Caption: contenders
Caption: if at all possible get your stakeholders
Caption: your party planners involved early and
Caption: make sure that you are on the same page
Caption: when it comes to what needs to be
Caption: delivered when
Caption: a plan ahead for rework for unexpected
Caption: tools and changes in your team and your
Caption: own capacity
Caption: deliver your minimum viable product and
Caption: then continue to improve on it if at all
Caption: possible
Caption: so how do we learn from my mistakes I
Caption: mean failure is inevitable sometimes
Caption: it's a big part of life it's part of
Caption: developing software
Caption: but you know those small mistakes that
Caption: I've made along the way that doesn't
Caption: have to snowball into a massive failure
Caption: so if you can ask yourself these couple
Caption: of questions the next time you're
Caption: working on a software project
Caption: are we all on the same page and is our
Caption: understanding documented
Caption: have we considered All Parts in our
Caption: development and our testing
Caption: and have we planned for when things go
Caption: wrong and is there a contingency plan in
Caption: place
Caption: if you can answer yes to these three
Caption: questions
Caption: then you would have at least learned
Caption: from my mistakes
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you Sarah that was so good